the hunter Biden scandals are far more
corrupt than you could ever have
imagined remember the infamous letter
signed by 51 former intelligence
officials saying the dirtbag's first
son's laptop was Russian disinformation
well it turns out that the Biden
campaign orchestrated the entire thing
xcia director Mike Morrell revealing in
sworn testimony that Secretary of State
now Secretary of State Anthony blinken
who was then a senior Biden campaign
advisor led the effort to release that
letter Republican Jim Jordan ripping
into the revelation
that letter became the basis for keeping
this information from the American
people and the other thing that was
important we learned in that deposition
with Mr Morrell is they were even Mr
Morrell was even trying to direct who
the Biden campaign told him who to get
this to in the media it was that
coordinated
it was a total political operation and
the most important fact is Laura it was
false
both Joe and Hunter used that letter as
proof to dismiss the laptop
there are 50 former National
Intelligence folks who said that what
this he's accusing me of is a Russian
plant they have said that this is has
all the Care four five former heads of
the CIA both parties say what he's
saying is a bunch of garbage certainly
it there could be a laptop out there
that was stolen from me there could be
that I was hacked it could be that there
was the that it was Russian intelligence
it could be that it was stolen from me
and now there's another damaging
development on top of the IRS
whistleblower according to a new report
there is growing frustration in the FBI
over why it's taking so long to charge
Hunter investigators wrapped up the
probe a year ago and are just sitting on
it we're also learning that Hunter
Biden's attorneys will meet with the doj
officials next week
okay now you know I want to start with
the 51 Intel officers and the fact that
they knew Martha that this was a
political operation that they were
involved in their credibility was online
both Republicans and Democrats former
heads of the CIA they didn't care enough
about truth and Justice and we found out
afterwards that people would have voted
differently that would have changed the
election possibly probably and yet
nobody seemed to care should we even
worry about more
you know I went back and read the letter
to remind myself what was in it and it's
so Superior it's basically like we we've
been around a long time we understand
the Russian government we know how their
minds work we know that you saw a laptop
with a bunch of salacious photos on it
and emails about 10 for the big guy but
hey we know what we're talking about
we're really smart we're Jim Clapper
we're John Brennan we're Mike Hayden
we're all these people who've been
around a long time and going and going
back to what you said Janine they were
asked to do this by the campaign and
Morel said you know we thought it would
quote help Biden they go on in this
letter to say you know what we firmly
believe that America the American people
have to be the ones who control the
elections they have to have the outcome
not a foreign government we wouldn't
want that to happen meanwhile you know
these members of the government are
trying to have a huge influence over
what happens here and I'll just finish
by saying that in the heart of this
letter they say look they sense the
Russians are sensing weakness they don't
think that Trump can win they they you
know don't they want him to win right
and if Biden wins they want to weaken
him they don't go on to say these 51
officials who are super smart about
Russia and if that happens Russia will
promptly invade Ukraine
[Music]
so this is it just smacks of this sort
of superior language in this whole
letter you don't believe what you saw
believe what we saw and now we know that
it had a political origin not a deeply
felt origin it's like they all called
each other and said you know what guys
I'm worried about this laptop thing I
just saw we all know this could you know
this this looks like it came from a
political motivation and you know
Lawrence the these guys were the head of
CIA many of the directors deputies some
of them they know how to confirm whether
or not something is real or not real all
you had to do was look at that laptop
and know what was in it see emails and
contact people who might have written
those emails is the Deep State as deep
as we thought well see that's just the
thing judge no one asked to look at the
last laptop I mean we're under this
impression that these people are honest
Brokers and they weren't because it was
all about getting their guy in and
everyone knows it now you know judge as
someone that travels around the country
and talk with American people on the
day-to-day basis this Republican primary
may be over before it even starts merely
based on the issue of fairness
Donald Trump didn't get reelected
because people didn't like his tone and
tenor what if it was justified what if
people were after him what if the
election as it relates to the
information that was being uh
disseminated wasn't fair we already have
polling data that says that people would
have changed their vote if they would
have known the Scandal between Joe Biden
and Hunter Biden and now we find out
that the intelligence committee the
people that we have the community the
people that still have security
clearances didn't even ask about the
laptop they were and then the secretary
of state was a political operative
I mean that is some shady business yeah
and that is the intelligence community
that caused so much trouble uh during
the Trump Administration but you know
one of the things uh that Geraldo that
I'm concerned about is now that we have
this whistleblower uh who's talking
about the grand jury presentation that
as with the grand jury has been finished
for a year it's been five years since
they began the investigation now what we
get is The Whistleblower as a lawyer
goes to Congress he says look I want to
protect my guy he's a high-level IRS guy
and what is Hunter Biden's lawyer come
out and say he comes out and he says
listen if anyone uh this IRS agent if
anyone's committed a crime the IRS agent
has it's a felony for an IRS agent to
improperly disclose information now the
IRS agent hasn't said anything other
than send his lawyer out and this is the
American we live in they want the guy
who wants a whistleblower protection to
be prosecuted and not Hunter Biden uh I
just want to remind everybody that I
supported Donald Trump when this was
happening I supported Donald Trump until
the day after he lost the election uh
and and insisted that he did not
but I remember thinking when the laptop
hit judge that this is too good to be
true this can't be out the president's
son is there smoking crackies with
hookers he's doing they this has to be
uh this is Russia I mean it it because
it was so it seemed like a setup it's
it's it I mean could the Sun be that bad
could uh the intelligence Community not
see through this and when I saw the
letter uh as Martha recalls I was uh you
know very impressed with it and I was I
was chagrined I was oh my goodness they
weren't that these are people that were
around Joe Biden they knew about his son
the Obama Administration even told Joe I
don't think I wonder if that's true I
wonder if that's true no exactly of
course literally bows from the Obama
Administration telling Hunter as well as
Joe Biden you can't be doing this the uh
the the White House council's office
told them to knock it off when he was
vice president it's been uh the quiet
Secret in Washington how out of control
right yeah by that point so I mean it
wasn't a secret that he was drugged that
yeah
I I got all that but but to think that
all of these names this very impressive
list and yes they are
if they were deep but they think that
all of them got together and said we're
going to go
with basement politics rather than some
Noble
state is there a deep State yeah uh I
don't know I I think that what they're
what there is is shallow people who do
everything for political games and who
intelligence community in the United
States of America Greg I want you to
take a listen to this
that Hunter Biden and a drunken stupor
dropped off his laptop do you think
stuff like that could just have been
planted in there and be completely fake
I do to me this is uh this classic
textbook uh Soviet Russian uh tradecraft
at work for all we know these emails are
made up or maybe some are real and
others are fakes we don't know as I and
several of my former colleagues have
pointed out publicly that it does bear
the Hallmarks of Russian disinformation
Greg yeah I mean uh the claim in the
letter is a hoax it's a hoax this was a
deep State smilet and we we talk about
how this happened there's a former CI
director to taking orders from the Biden
campaign to gather up Intel agents to
create a hoax right and then this story
almost always ends there but we never go
further
that letter had to go somewhere right it
was an exclusive for Natasha Bertrand is
that her name at Politico why her like
how did she get the letter how deep was
she involved because this is important
she was the same reporter who was behind
the dossier she was put she pushed that
thing so hard she made it appear that
there are all these Outlets I don't know
if you guys remember this about the
dossier it was it was the it was
Business Insider it was the Atlantic it
was Politico but she was the sole author
but it sounded like this was going
around and around and around and the
result is not necessarily corroborating
evidence because there wasn't any she
got a job at MSNBC they rewarded her
despite the fact that she was wrong on
everything and you think well maybe
maybe you learn a lesson from that but
then they then this laptop hoax comes up
and they feed it to her and why because
she was masterful at the Russian dossier
hoax so that that's why she got rewarded
so it should have set off the alarms
which she was behind that letter which
she got that letter first everybody in
in journalism said wait a second that's
the same that's the same person that
pushed this this dossier she's wholly
unreliable and oh wait a second that's
why she has it that's why she has it so
and then yet they all played along and
to my knowledge she still has a job
she's known as a national security
reporter how is that even possible the
two biggest lies of the last three years
she pushed
you know the sad part about all of this
is that it was interference in a
presidential election should be illegal
should have believed the New York is a
crime hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else